I am that obje Shirin from the Qi group
I am the executive chairman and the
question I'm answering here is what role
do women play in the future of East Asia
women have played a very strong role in
East Asia then traditionally they have
played a strong role in East Asia and in
Asia posad and in any other part of the
world if one were to take a look at the
Indian subcontinent for instance we have
had more leaders than in any other part
of the world both India Pakistan Sri
Lanka and Bangladesh have all had women
leaders we have prime ministers of
Thailand and president of Indonesia
basically the president of Philippines
have all been leaders and yet we still
yet to see a president of the United
States who is a a woman leader so women
have played a strong and powerful and
positive role all throughout Asia and
it's a developing countries in Asia to
have the advantage of women playing
positive and playing dynamic roles the
Challenger though has been actually the
reverse seeing women play stronger roles
in more established first world
countries such as Japan Korea and for
that matter the United States or even
France now if one were to take for
example the fact that women are shaping
the future in Asia today and yet at the
bottom of the pyramid so to speak women
are still struggling to find equality
that is a challenge that has to be dealt
with nd and the answer to that lies in
their own songs hoochies remark today
which is knowledge is empowerment and in
the arena of women's emancipation
knowledge is truly empowerment it is
true knowledge it is true education that
we can truly uplift the plight of women
we can truly uplift the cultural and the
bias on against gender and it is true
knowledge and an education that we can
bypass this there by lifting women to
where he can lead the world